Danny, why are you
crawling around in the dark?
Lisa: Were you actually asleep?
Danny: Of course not.
I was trying
to save on lightbulbs.
Lisa: Haven't slept
for about two months.
Chronic insomnia.
Danny: Hypnotism, acupuncture,
none of it works.
- You still up?
- How was your day?
Ooh! I saw this ad for
some new pills called Snoozers.
No, they don't knock you out.
They just make everything
taste like cabbage…
- apart from cabbage.
- (Lisa laughs)
Lisa: Aw, it's a little dog.
Little? I could put a saddle
on it and ride it into town.
(Laughs)
Sorry, it's my bedtime.
Mwah!
- Hey!
- There you are.
Danny: You remember that dating
app that you signed me up for?
- I got a match.
- That's great!
Who kept calling you all night?
- Lisa?
- We're just mates.
Amy: Not from where
I'm standing.
Veggie: When I'm sleeping,
there's this
whole world of Lisa's
that I know nothing about.
- Hello.
- I'm not stealing.
- What?
- Oh, my God!
There's a big bunch of cows.
Cows?
- Do cows attack?
- Let me check.
Yeah, yeah, they do attack.
- And they do… and they kill.
- What?
♪
Veggie: I don't think
you know what it's like
for your partner to come alive
as soon as you go to bed.
Lisa: I don't know
what I want to do.
Danny: We're all
trying our best.
All it takes is that one person
to really see you.
- Tonight is the big night.
- First date.
I've come up with a few ideas
to help her feel more at ease.
Why don't you just put
a padlock on your fly?
I think that'll really
put her at ease.
'Cause it…
- what do you mean, really?
- No!